I was like oh it's the stripper I
ordered we had a Barbie sleepover for
all the Barbies we went to claridge's
and Greta organized it and we literally
were like in our pajamas playing games
and ordering room service the Ken's were
invited to stop by but obviously not
allowed to sleep over Ryan couldn't make
it he didn't want to sleep over anyway
and uh so instead he had other things to
do he sent a singing telegram
and yeah there was like a knock at the
door and everyone's like who's that
we're all here and I was like as a joke
I was like oh it's the stripper I
ordered and then when I opened the door
it's like sorry about the older guy and
it killed walked in and everyone was
like oh this is gonna be weird and I was
like no I was joking I didn't order a
stripper I don't know who this is